I guess we'll just affirm you see a very
versatile thanks a lot for inviting me
the key notion in this talk is going to
be approximation by polynomials point
wise approximation so the key quantity
is e of F and D F here is an arbitrary
boolean function and E of F and E is the
minimum error to which F can be
approximated in the Infinity norm by a
polynomial of degree at most D and so
the polynomial can be an arbitrary bound
on with real real coefficients and we're
interested in point wise approximation
so you can approximate any function to
error 0 by a polynomial of degree n
simply by interpolating it on the other
hand for smaller values of D this
quantity is going to be between 0 and 1
so these are trivial bounds
approximating a function by polynomials
reveals a great deal of information
about the function in particular lower
bounds for polynomial approximation
translate into hardness impossibility
results and lower bounds in a variety of
models such as circuit complexity
quantum query query coupling complexity
communication complexity on the other
hand upper balance for approximation
translating to algorithmic results
including learning theoretic
applications applications more generally
to algorithm design such as inclusion
exclusion algorithms and most recently
applications to differential privacy
actually in recent years there have been
papers that have taken lower bounds for
approximation and turn them now I have
taken upper bounds for approximation and
turn them into lower balance in
complexity theory so so the separation
isn't quite as strict
the first function that was studied in
this area of in this body of work is the
half space so this is the oldest problem
it has been studied roughly since the
60s and the question is what is the
worst case air to which a half space can
be approximated point-wise by half space
I mean I mean an arbitrary function that
that can be expressed as the sine of
some linear combination of the inputs
and we'll be interested in half spaces
over the boolean hypercube a long time
ago in the 60s a variety of authors have
proved a lower bound of one - an
exponentially small quantity in n on the
approximation error for explicit half
spaces and this is essentially tied
because you can construct you can for a
T half space you can round the
coefficients such that their magnitudes
their absolute values do not exceed and
to the N so this sort of matches the
trivial upper bound as well but not
quite there's a logarithmic gap which
johann filled in so his construction is
a great deal more subtle and it
definitively settles the gap I think I
think even up to the multiplicative
factor in the exponent
however the the question for larger
values of G has remained wide open for
quite a while we didn't have such a
tight approximation there's such a tight
pair of upper and lower bounds this was
more or less the state of the art for
the past well up to ten years ago so
these two lower bounds are incomparable
and sort of a fragmented state of
affairs so we know that some half space
requires a very high degree for
approximation to constantly err on the
other hand there's another half space
that that cannot be approximated except
you know exponentially close to random
exponentially close to the trivial error
but there the degree parameter is is
smaller than n so it's a fragmented
state of affairs and it's not clear what
the general dependence should be then
ten years ago and we obtained this bound
using the probabilistic method so unlike
all these other results in this table
this last entry is non constructive and
it's an existence proof that uses the
probabilistic method in its in an
essential way quantitatively it is
satisfying because it shows that there's
a half space such that approximating it
for any degree parameter is as bad as it
can possibly be so the lower bound here
for any degree D matches the trivial
upper bound for degree one so you can
approximate that half space trivially to
roughly 1 minus 2 to the N 1 minus 2 to
the minus n and that's the best that you
can get for any degree unless you go
essentially all the way out to n in
which case there finally drops down to
zero and that construction once again is
not explicit now in all these
constructions the focus should be on
this exponent which is typeset in this
tiny font but in all applications what
happens is you consider 1 minus there
and you take the reciprocal of that so
really what we're interested in is the
exponent of this error term
okay the main result of this talk is an
explicit construction of a half space
that matches the quantitative behavior
from the previous slide so approximating
it by degree D polynomial incurs a point
wise error of 1 - an exponentially small
quantity nen this is as bad as it can be
and would prove a corresponding lower
bound for rational approximation which
is important for some of the other
applications of this work so there the
dependence in the exponent is n over D
where D is the degree and both of these
lower bounds are are optimal and a
quadratic exponent our quadratic
improvement on previous explicit
construction yeah right so if you allow
approximation by rational functions then
very quickly get better
okay I think this is this is a very
natural and clean problem I've been
interested in it off and on for the
pasta the past eight years
but it's only this year that I was able
to piece together the the puzzle pieces
and make this construction explicit
epsilon is some constant so it's you can
take it larger than than a hundred but I
haven't really invested any effort in
that okay as a corollary we'll construct
an intersection of two half spaces that
cannot be approximated to any error
better than the trivial area of one
unless you allow approximants of degree
linear in n so put another would put
another way this intersection of two
half spaces cannot be approximated it
cannot be represented by the sign of a
polynomial of degree unless the of
degree less than some constant times n
okay so these again are our quadratic
improvement on previous explicit
constructions so this is a workshop on
interactive complexity and a driving
factor driving motivating factor behind
this work has been communication
complexity specifically the problem of
separating discrepancy and sign rank
which are two fundamental notions in the
area so here we consider a randomized
communication with two parties so
there's some function with n bit
arguments and both parties have access
to a private string of random bits in
addition to their respective inputs so R
sub epsilon is the minimum cost of an
epsilon err protocol for a function in
this model obviously if you allow the
air to increase all the way up to 1/2
the communication complexity starts to
drop and the limit of the communication
complexity or should say the minimum
this is a discrete quantity as the air
parameter goes up to 1/2 is known as the
unbounded air communication complexity
so it's a it's a very well studied
notion mathematically it's some of the I
think most beautiful work in in the area
because it's very rich it's connected to
algebraic geometry a variety of other
ideas ok
but you can also consider a slightly
modified quantity where in addition to
looking at the communication complexity
you add in a penalty term that depends
on epsilon so as epsilon approaches 1/2
the penalty term gets large to reflect
the fact that you're achieving smaller
and smaller advantage over random
guessing ok this quantity is known as
the visit so the first the former the
first quantity is known as the unbounded
err communication complexity this
quantity is known as the communication
complexity with weekly unbounded air so
it's not bounded away from 1/2 but but
almost
all right so I guess so one one way to
motivate it is to say that it is exactly
equivalent to a notion known as
discrepancy which is sort of the central
notion in all of communication
complexity but a more sort of a more
independent line of reasoning would go
as follows
so this term needs to so you need to
consider the difference of 1/2 minus
epsilon because epsilon is sort of the
limit that you're approaching take the
reciprocal of that so it'll be some some
function of the form 2 to the some some
exponent and it's that exponent that
you're really interested in so it's not
sort of natural to take the logarithm of
that and the mathematics bears it out
because it turns out to be exactly
equivalent to the discrepancy of F by
that and so the discrepancy of F is
actually the this quantity exponentiated
and then the reciprocal of that whereas
the sign rank of F is this quantity
exponentiated so morally speaking these
two notions correspond precisely to the
unvalidated complexity and communication
complexity with weakly unbounded air
basically whatever function you like
that it's the same quantity the second
one it's just when epsilon is very close
to one and just in the difference say
that again
it's some differential you can if you
wait our tree me like a multiplicative
factor here yes so using a different
doesn't make a difference okay yeah
that's true that's true
1 over 1 minus X is 1 plus X yeah so
these two notions are are extensively
studied there are sturdy bridges that
connect communication complexity to
fields and topics such as Banach space
theory algebraic geometry Learning
Theory combinatorics all communication
complexity is already a combinatorial
subject to start with but
now once you have defined two complexity
measures you can consider the
corresponding complexity classes so UPP
is the set of communication problems
whose communication complexity with
unbounded air is poly logarithmic in n
and likewise P P is the set of
communication problems whose
communication complexity is poly
logarithmic in n with weakly unbounded
air both of these complexity classes are
communication complexity analogues of
the class P P in Turing machine
complexity and in 1986 by by Franklin
Simon in their fundamental paper on
communication complexity classes posed
the problem of separating these two
classes so by definition if you're
computing something with weakly
unbounded air then that gives you less
power than computing with unbounded air
and they asked whether the separation is
strict so this question was answered in
2007 in two independent works with two
quite different functions and the caps
are also different in the first case the
gap is log n versus n to the N to the
one third in the second case log n log n
versus root n now in in recent years the
functioning question has been simplified
so Justin Taylor gave a beautiful
separation where the function is a
particularly simple function it's I
think a decision list but certainly it's
a function computable and AC zero with
very small depth and this work achieves
the largest possible separation of log n
versus n so it's a polynomial
improvement on previous constructions
and it's as bad as it can be so the
unbounded our communication complexity
is log N and the communication
complexity with weekly unbounded error
is
as large as it can be and I should say
that this extends communication with
three or more parties in that context
obviously the best separation was also
log n nothing was known better than
Morgan versus root n so this applies
using the pattern matrix method to the
to the multi-party context as well okay
this is the communication this is the
application to communication complexity
I'll also mention our application to
learning theory here's the sort of girl
hand-in-hand here the focus will be on
the intersection of two half spaces so
this is the corollary from the first few
introductory slides of this talk the
problem the learning problem of a level
of relevance here is that of learning
the intersection of two half spaces so
we have some two half spaces let's say
you're working in the Euclidean space
and you don't actually observe the half
spaces you only get examples that are
sampled independently according to some
distribution and they're labeled
according to whether they are inside the
intersection or outside so the problem
of approximate aproximately learning in
this intersection of two half spaces is
one of the most fundamental in the area
important special cases of this problem
have been solved specifically if you put
some restrictions on the distribution
some some natural restrictions such as
the uniform distribution on the sphere
or on the hypercube so their algorithms
are available or if you impose geometric
constraints on this problem by requiring
for example that the points be far away
from the intersection of half spaces
then methods like random projection
become useful and allow you to
essentially reduce this problem to the
very low dimension where you can learn
it using good for search but outside of
these two cases where you impose
structural restrictions or you require
something
about the distribution you really can't
say anything so there's no algorithm
better than the trivial algorithm with
running time to to thee and for learning
the intersection of even two half spaces
on the boolean hypercube and this
problem has been studied for a really
long time most annoyingly we don't even
have evidence that this problem should
be hard in fact at the end of the talk
as one of my problems I'll mention a
conjecture that this problem should
actually be feasible in and for me in an
information theoretic sense yeah so the
only impossibility results that we have
at this point are for proper learning
where the hypothesis actually needs to
be an intersection of two half spaces no
reason to require it okay and the only
other the only other hardness results or
the lower bounds are for the
intersection of polynomial emini half
spaces so there you have an extremely
complex polytope not just the
intersection of two half spaces but a
very complex polytope which can compute
lots of functions and that is known to
be off limits under standard
cryptographic assumptions but the basic
problem learning the intersection of two
half spaces is wide open anyway as with
most functions in learning theory the
state-of-the-art algorithms whether it's
in the PAC model in the agnostic model
or a variety of other models arise from
polynomials specifically
state-of-the-art algorithms for DNA for
learning DNF formulas and read ones
formulas all come about by expressing
the unknown function as the sign of a
low degree polynomial and using for
example the linear programming algorithm
the tiller to learn this unknown
polynomial so the question is can this
be done for the intersection of two half
spaces and again it was studied for for
quite a while eight years ago the slower
was obtained finally that shows that you
cannot express the intersection of two
half spaces by a polynomial of degree
less than n so if you have a single half
space then that's a polynomial of degree
one the lowest possible degree whereas
if you have the intersection of two
copies of such a half space then all of
a sudden the degree jumps all the way to
N and here as a corollary of our main
result we're able to make the may to
construct constructor explicitly so
think of it as constructing a really
small exponentially small hard core
inside the concept class of the
intersection of two half spaces and that
hard core is as hard to learn as the
rest of the class with respect to all
known approaches so here I think I think
no it's it's it's not not at all as I
think as compelling as the communication
complexity problem there we are
interested truly in explicit separations
for example there there there are
several instances where existential
separations are very easy to prove such
as deterministic versus randomized
communication complexity with three or
more parties but proving it explicitly
is a very difficult open problem so in
the communication complexity context
explicitness is a big deal here I see it
as as having aesthetic value so it sort
of allows you to really look at so you
know constructs this half space that is
off-limits to all known algorithmic
approaches so I sort of see it as as
adding a aesthetic value to this line of
impossibility results buddy all right
yeah so my main my main motivation for
working on it was a because I consider
it a natural clean problem that
has been studied basically since the 60s
and be because it gives this tight
separation in communication complexity
is that is it a randomized thing under
some distribution there's some
distribution which produces hard
instances or is it really just somehow
so you know no it's it's a randomized
algorithm that succeeds with high
probability
but is it samples coefficients from some
from some sample sample space and the
the rat the non explicit construction
from previous work gives absolutely no
clue for what a good candidate should be
so that is something that that was a
stumbling block for me because I was
interested in constructing it explicitly
eight years ago and so it's just not
even clear how to how that hard have how
that hardest half space should look like
so you know it's general form it's it's
when you pick coefficients at random
from some from some range independently
in random and this is essentially what
the the randomized construction does
then you know you have you can you can
reason about the structure of this half
space sort of using a variety of tools
but actually constructing these
coefficients yeah you have to you
construct an actual integer that'll be
the first coefficient and a second
coefficient third coefficient and it's
totally unclear where to start
so yeah that's what I consider cool
about this problem because you have to
construct this half space by specifying
a normal vector for that half space and
so what exactly should that normal
vector V any questions before we jump
into the technical part of the talk so
from now on I will not mention
applications until the very end
the very last slide of open questions
and I'll just focus on this technical
result of constructing the hardest half
space yeah so once once you construct
the hardest half space then the
intersection of two copies of it are the
hardest for for sign representation so
the focus is is on the main theorem
where we construct a half space that is
the hardest from the point of view of
approximation by polynomials and
rational functions yeah and that's what
we'll focus on the definition of B right
yeah so um well we'll see it though oh
yeah yeah that's great that's great okay
so e of F and D where F is an arbitrary
boolean function is the minimum over all
polynomials of degree
all the air okay so the contrast is you
can start it out okay let's let's try
another one
start it out not too bad but but I think
it's not okay this is much better
okay now the the previously low contrast
part is now a very high contrast on the
upside and the rational approximation is
the rational approximation error is
defined analogously for rational
functions instead of polynomials alright
so what is the proof strategy and the
proof strategy is is to say what is the
brute force approach to approximating a
half space the brute force approach uses
black box approximation so you take take
that linear combination that corresponds
to your half space and you just do the
dumbest thing possible you take this
linear combination and you pass it as an
argument to a univariate approximation
for the sine function I mean this is
this is the the simplest thing that you
can do so do not open up this linear
combination do not look at the
individual bits just take this linear
combination and pass it in a black box
manner to a univariate approximation for
the sine function so we call such
approximations approximants black box
approximate these are really cool
approximants because analyzing them is
you know a few sentences worth of is an
argument that's a few sentences long
understanding the sine function is
completely understood with respect to
polynomial approximation and rational
approximation so such approximants are
very well studied but the question is is
black box approximation does black box
approximation give you any information
about general approximation I mean a
priori there is no reason to expect that
of the optimal approximate necessarily
treats this linear combination as an
atomic unit and doesn't open it up and
look at the individual coefficients
I mean this sounds really too good to be
true the only circumstance where it is
known to be optimal is where the
coefficients are all the same so there
it's known as the symmetrization
argument and in general as you can
expect this black box approximation is
pretty pathetic if you consider this
particular half space then it's an
exercise a simple exercise to see that
you can approximate it to any error
arbitrarily small so any nonzero error
by a by rational functional degree 1 so
it's as easy as it can possibly be but
if you were to treat it as an atomic
unit then of course you would require
degree and in fact 2 to the N however
the hope and sort of the the guiding
principle behind our approach is that it
should be possible to construct
coefficients for which looking at the
individual bits does not reveal any
additional information on top of what is
revealed by looking at the overall
linear combination and we're
specifically interested in constructing
coefficients such that the range of the
sum is is this exponentially large range
so that the problem is actually hard
even for black box approximants and more
importantly we're interested in ensuring
that when you consider polynomials and
rational functions of degree less than
epsilon and then they really do not get
any advantage if they look at individual
bits as opposed to looking at the linear
combination yeah so it has to be this
exponentially large interval because you
know at the end of the day of the
argument goes as follows you start with
an arbitrary approximate then you
construct from it
a univariate approximant of comparable
complexity so if it's a rational
function then the numerator and
denominator degree will have to be this
will have to be roughly the same as the
original approximate and that's why you
need this exponentially large range
because you want to argue that that a
univariate approximate needs to have a
large degree okay so once once we
construct these coefficients then the
rest of the where we're basically home
free because that means that any
approximate of degree Epsilon and for
some small constant required gives you a
univariate approximate for the sine
function on this exponentially large
range and sine function is complete the
sine function is completely understood
and the lower bounds just fall out
immediately from then on so the hard
part is constructing this these
coefficients such that looking at
individual bits does not leak any
information on top of what is revealed
by the linear combination itself that's
sort of the the idea the main idea in
the proof so that is the crux see so
that is that is the heart the heart part
of the proof it's this magic wand that
that you know allows you to argue that
any approximate for this half space
needs to treat this linear combination
as atomic if it doesn't it doesn't get
any any any advantage with respect to
degree
okay so now let's focus on constructing
the coefficients the first step now
involves a notion of discrepancy which
is completely unrelated to the notional
discrepancy on the first slide so this
is nothing to do with communication
complexity here consider an arbitrary
set of integers we will allow repeated
entries and the notional discrepancy
that will be interested in is with
respect to the free a basis for the
group Z M so we're looking so Z is the
multi set of integers that's given to us
and we're looking at the maximum over
all K all this exponential some W is any
AM fruit of unity it doesn't matter
which and which would have unity you use
so when you stare at this for a few
moments you realize that this is
actually something quite familiar this
is quite simply the maximum magnitude of
a non-constant fourier coefficient of
the characteristic vector of z if it's
an actual set and it's really literally
the the characteristic vector of z if
it's a multi set then it's the frequency
vector where the components correspond
to the frequencies of the individual
elements and that is why the constant
coefficient is excluded because it's the
same no matter what set you use okay so
obviously this notion is invariant under
reduction of the elements of Z modulo M
and if you consider the set of all
integers 0 1 2 3 3 and minus 1 then that
of course has discrepancy 0 so we're
interested in constructing very tiny
sets that have discrepancy close to 0
pictorially here's how you should think
about this you should think of the
discrepancy you have a set of integers
as a measure of a periodicity or a
measure of
balanced nests this is some sort of
pseudo-random complexity measure so
let's say that this is and this is the
integer interval from 0 to n minus 1 and
these are the the elements of Z consider
a specific character of the free a
Fourier transform so this character for
example let's just focus on the real
part you see that these two points hit a
low of the character and that one hits a
low point and that one hits a high point
so the average is sort of bounded away
from 1/2 so it's not bounded away from 1
and if you consider maybe another
character then you're hitting a high
point here a low point there
low point there and a high point there
so the half rate is actually almost
exactly zero so you want the points to
be placed in a very clever way such that
no matter what for your character you
consider you're hitting roughly the
highs of that character as often as
you're hitting the lows of the character
so the sum comes out to zero roughly so
right so mm is fixed em for us will be 2
to the N so it'll be some exponentially
large quantity and we want to construct
this set as small as possible such that
it such that it is a periodic if you for
example if you take Z to be some
arithmetic progression then it'll have
horrible discrepancy no very high
all right so if you pick the elements of
the of the set uniformly at random then
by applying the Chernoff bound or the
hefting bound you can easily verify that
the discrepancy of this set will be very
small in particular you know if you take
logarithmic dependence on m and inverse
polynomial dependence on epsilon that
suffices so this so this would be this
would be great for us except that this
is completely non constructive and by
the way so this is this is not not
either for the talk it's a parenthetical
parenthetical remark you cannot
construct something smaller than log n
again that's a simple exercise in so
there there are many proofs of that fact
all of them essentially from first
principles okay so don't read this lemma
try not to look at it in fact I'll tell
you what its role is and in the in the
in the talk so somehow we need to
construct this a periodic set Z so how
do we go about doing that this this
problem has been studied before was
studied in the 90s and to the best of my
knowledge there are only two solutions
there there's a solution from first
principles which is the one that that we
use in this in this talk and that is
then there's another solution due to
cuts that that uses advanced number
theory and achieves a slightly better
parameters but in the range that we're
interested in the construction due to IT
at all which is from first principles
and much simpler is abundantly
sufficient so what do I tie in all do
they first consider very small primes
and construct a periodic sets modulo
those Prime's then they consider
slightly larger Prime's and use this
earlier construction
to construct on a periodic set modulo
the slightly larger collection of primes
and so on and so forth
so they proceed iteratively in this
fashion and eventually they're able to
construct an a periodic set for an
arbitrarily large modulus now in each
step you go from a prime P to roughly
something like 2 to the P so this this
is a very rapid process and what they do
in their work is achieve discrepancy
that is vanishingly small and the set
the thickens the construct is
unfortunately for us
super logarithmic so what we do is we
modify their argument somewhat by
cutting off this iterative process after
just two stages and then resorting to
brute-force search so this is this is
how we obtain our dependence on Epsilon
and you can do this for an arbitrarily
small constant Epsilon yeah so the
difference from their argument is to not
apply this iterative process too long
because then you're you're you know the
size of the set becomes super
logarithmic so we cut it off there after
just two stages and that is enough
because after two stages the input size
is so small it's if you do for three
stages it will be log log log n so with
input size that small you can construct
a periodic sets that are explicit with
respect to any thinkable measure of
explicitness log space anything okay so
this is the first the first step of the
proof the second step is to consider the
corresponding random walk on on ZM so
here are our coefficients they come from
an a periodic set that we constructed in
the previous set in the previous step
and now we're going to analyze the
distribution of this
or this linear form so the coefficients
are fixed and then the excise are bits
there's zero one and we're going to
reduce the sum modulo M so ideally as
you pick a random point a random bit
vector X then this should be uniformly
distributed modulo M and the hope and
this is what we're going to show right
now is that if you take on a periodic
set then by taking a random weighted by
by by considering this this linear
combination where the X's are uniformly
random bits you consider you you get a
uniformly random point of ZM this sort
of makes sense so that is this is why
you need the a periodicity because if if
the coefficients were part of an
arithmetic progression then this would
not converge to the uniform distribution
you would be stuck on you know on this
restricted subset okay so to see why
this is uniformly distributed on ZM for
a periodic said see it's helpful to view
this as an N step random walk and
consider the corresponding transition
matrix for the nth step of the random
walk which looks like this so with
probability 1/2 you stay put with
probability 1/2 you add the coefficients
Z sub J so certainly this is the shift
from the origin okay so this is a
circulant matrix and all these circulant
matrices are simultaneously
diagonalisable in the free a basis so
this is what we're gonna do we're
interested in their product which
corresponds to the N and step random
walk and by diagonalizing each matrix in
this product we arrive at this product
so now let's take these unitary out and
we have the product of the diagonal
matrices on the inside where Omega is
any and through any Ameth root of unity
so here using a few additional lines of
argument and you can show that each of
these quantities is bounded in absolute
value in terms of the discrepancy of the
original set so if your set is a
periodic then provably the random walk
converges to something uniform on 0 1 2
3 3 n minus 1 okay so this is the
technical statement if you consider the
probability of getting a particular
specific value modulo M then the
probability that probability minus 1
over m is going to be very small it'll
be exponentially small where the base of
Peaks where the base of the exponential
is small growth is the discrepancy
parameter if your discrepancy is 1 so
this is the setting where you're using
the trivial construction and you're not
a periodic at all you're very a periodic
you're very periodic then you get
nothing so this difference is going to
be large as large as 1 so intuitively
this makes sense with respect to on the
parameters absolutely right yeah
anything that's bounded away from 1 is
fine for us right so if you plug in some
1 minus epsilon here you get
exponentially fast decay and that that's
sufficient for our purposes ok step 3
so we're almost almost done constructing
the half space this is sort of the
critical step let's set epsilon to be
sufficiently small so this is this is a
question this is a question that mother
asked at the beginning of the talk I'm
99% confident that Betty can be again it
can be taken to be 1/100 but taking it
one over 2018 definitely works and again
so the constant is not material the
modulus that will work where
is this exponentially large value to to
the some constant times n and these the
eyes are what they have been throughout
this talk
they are elements of an a periodic set
okay
so let's consider the linear function
from the previous step just the linear
form into Z m and we know that as you
vary X over as you take X to be a random
point of the hypercube then this is
uniformly distributed on CM so because
of that the expectations of any
polynomial on the preimage of L on the
preimage of Z is is the same as the
expectation of any polynomial on the
preimage of L on the preimage of 1 under
l and so on and so forth in other words
as you consider the the expectation of
any polynomial over all points for which
this linear form is 0 mod M or want mod
M or 2 mod M or M minus 1 mod M in each
case you're getting roughly the same
value so this this follows from from
step 2 using you know by by expanding
this out and considering the the
coefficients but what you can actually
show is that you can achieve equality
here exact straight equality if you
perturb the co-efficient slightly so
here we're considering the uniform
distribution over all points X that
forced the linear sum to be 0 modulo M
here it's all points so the hypercube
that forced the sum to be 1 modulo M and
so on and so forth if you perturb these
distributions while remaining inside
their corresponding supports then you
can achieve strict equality no no it's
it's by no means a generic alright so
you can easily construct counter
examples even when the approximate
equality is say the approximate
equalities are are exponentially close
but you cannot achieve exact equality so
this is quite special to the
distributions that we work with yeah
it's it's quite tailor to our setting
but but but but this is did this holes
did this should give this you can prove
step two step two is this phantom walk
yeah which what's it accomplished right
right so so far so the the big the big
picture that that that is that they
should be thinking of is we want to
argue that it makes it it gives you no
advantage to open up this linear form
and look at individual bits you don't
get any additional information on top of
what you would get by considering it as
an atomic unit so this is it's a bit of
a subtle argument which we haven't seen
yet but the critical the critical part
of that argument is that no matter what
polynomial you consider the average of
that polynomial over points of the
hypercube that force this linear sum to
be 0 mod m is the same as the average
over all points of the hypercube that
forced this linear
to be one model and so on and so forth
so intuitively you know the polynomial
already has that information by
considering just the weight at some I
mean looking at the way that some gives
you that that information gives you the
the residue class modulo m and you can
you can't derive any additional
information by considering individual
bits and that that is the last step of
the proof which let's just step four
it's a perturbation argument that uses
gears Gordon's disk theorem basically
you consider you said that you set up a
matrix that is diagonally dominant and
moreover it is strongly diagonally
dominant so most of the weight is on the
diagonal which means that you can invert
it and by inverting it you get a
probability distribution so a function
that is non-negative
at every point and and that inversion
argument does not hold in general so in
our specific context in our setting it's
true
but in general it does not hold if it if
it held if it were true in general then
for example you could take an arbitrary
half space and make its coefficients
polynomial is small which is not true
yeah you don't care what they are right
so you'll see right you'll see the role
of the new is in the next and final step
so so this is the final step of the
argument where we prove that opening up
this linear form and looking at
individual bits gives you no advantage
you might as well consider it as an
atomic unit okay so here's the fun
here's the half space that we'll be
working with I'm here
it's maybe a stupid question what if you
take zi to be 2 to the line so you get
the uniform distribution gives the
uniform distribution well so so that
that but but but that function is so it
has an approximate of degree 1 so it is
this probability of Z I used oh you'll
see you'll see in a second so so so
it'll it'll become clear when one would
go through the final step so go through
this and then I'll then answer that
question so the the the example that
you're thinking of hazard as an
approximate of degree 1 so you you'll
see that it it you know said but but
hang on for just a second and I'll get
back to that to that question ok so this
is the half space that we are
considering the Z eyes are the a
periodic set that we constructed two
steps ago and then we're going to
subtract off so this is an off set that
we're going to subtract off such that we
are just focusing on the residue modulo
M because you know ultimately the
function is is governed by by its sign
so the polynomial it's it's it's
sufficient so if I were to to not use
this offset then you know the polynomial
could just get the sign right and that
would be enough to compute the function
well we're going to remove and we're
going to subtract out this offset and
that'll force the polynomial to have to
figure out the actual residue class of
the bits modulo M and that it cannot do
reliably
so this is the function that we're
working with
and it's a half space on the hypercube
of dimension 2n and let's say that we
that someone gives us an approximate of
arbitrary degree it doesn't matter what
the degrees of the numerator and
denominator are one of them could be
large the other one could be small it
doesn't matter as long as both of them
are at most some constant times epsilon
to n variables because so here we have n
variables corresponding to the
individual bits and this is an integer
valued variable from 0 to n so you can
view it as the sum of n independent bits
okay so by the previous slide we have
these distributions mu sub s for every
value of s such that they are supported
on the points of the hypercube
that force the linear combination to be
s modulo M and when we subtract out s
then the resulting the resulting integer
is is a multiple of two to the epsilon M
there is a multiple of the modulus so
this is between zero one and
okay so how does the argument end this
is what you're given to start with so
you know that the rational function P
over Q which could be a polynomial if Q
is equal to Q equals one you know that
that rational function approximates the
plus one minus one valued function f at
every point within Delta so he can view
this you can rewrite this in as follows
by and end up way you avoid fractions of
polynomials ratios of polynomials no I
think it's right because so so
originally you have P divided by Q sorry
right right so you multiply that by F
and then the result will be almost
exactly one right because F is plus one
minus one valued and then without loss
of generality you can assume that the
either the numerator is always positive
or the denominator is always positive
and then you can convert it to this to
this long form okay so now we're going
to substitute this form for the second
argument
so this step does not require any any
facts we're just literally substituting
something for the second argument and
you know okay so so F under the
substitution simplifies to the sine of f
the sine of s unsurprisingly because
this is exactly what what we wanted to
achieve we wanted to prove that
approximating F is as hard as
approximating the sine function on this
exponentially large interval okay and
this here and this is the crucial
crucial final step of the argument this
is a polynomial in the X's and in s now
we're going to pasture expectations with
respect to U sub s
is these inequalities hold at every
point so we can consider their
expectation of these inequalities over
mu sub s but when you do that the X's
get expected out and it doesn't matter
what s you use so s on the support of MU
sub s is a constant it gets taken
outside the expectation operator so
whatever it remains inside is just the
x's and that expectation does not depend
on s that's where we needed the previous
slide so no matter what polynomial you
consider the expected value of that
polynomial under mu s is going to be the
same no matter what s you consider so
the polynomial does not distinguish
among the different residue classes
modulo m and here you take the outside
the expectation operator whatever
remains on the inside is a constant so
there if because you've taken an
arbitrary approximate and you have
converted it into a univariate
approximate for the sine function and we
know everything about the sine function
that that that we could possibly hope to
know so specifically you get the lower
bounds that that are claimed in the main
theorem
okay so these are the corollaries for
the polynomial approximation and the
rational approximation
okay two concrete open problems come to
mind naturally from this work the first
open problem is where their sign rank
low sign rank is preserved under
interest intersection it's a famous open
question that's been open since the 80s
you can think of it as whether upp is
closed under intersection or you can
think it think of it as whether low sign
rank is preserved under intersection so
you're given a a matrix that is entry
wise the the sign of some low rank
matrix and then you give it another such
matrix consider their component wise
conjunction does that matrix have also
small sign rank it would be crazy if
that were true but whole techniques that
we have at our disposal fail quite badly
so it at this point it's a it's not
clear how to proceed but but but I would
be very surprised if if you could take
two matrices of well sign rank and take
their conjunction that are the result
would still be a low sign rank okay
another open problem has to do with
learning theory there the the goal would
be to prove a far-reaching
generalization of our results that is
information theoretic so the application
to learning theory that I mentioned at
the beginning of the talk rules out
current algorithmic approaches whereas
this second point second bullet would
unconditionally rule out from a
statistical point of view any learning
algorithm in the statistical query model
so this will be the hardest sort of the
strongest impossibility result for
proving for the intersection of two half
spaces that we could prove for the
problem you cannot prove anything
unconditionally for all
possible approaches because that would
mean that P is not equal to NP but
statistically this would be sort of the
strongest lower bound that you could
hope for so I probably take me a lot
longer to explain them than I have time
to do right now but the statistical
query dimension is is a complexity
measure that corresponds to the
discrepancy under product distributions
in communication in the communication
complexity world in in the learning
world it corresponds to the existence
inside your your complexity class of a
large family of functions that are
pairwise orthogonal approximately
pairwise orthogonal and you are you're
allowed to use arbitrary distributions
on the domain so you have this
complexity class you put an arbitrary
probability distribution that's of your
choosing
on the points of the domain and then you
argue that there is a large collection
of functions inside your concept class
that are pairwise orthogonal for example
if you consider the set of parity
functions and then they are thuggin all
with respect to the uniform distribution
and there are lots of them and they're
exponentially many of them so the class
of parity functions cannot be learned in
the statistical query model and that is
a very strong lower bound because it
rules out any kind of robust learning
and does so unconditionally so if we
could have that for the intersection of
two half spaces then that would be a
far-reaching generalization of this
result that would I mean for all
practical purposes show that the problem
is not tractable right now
there's a there's a chasm between what
is what we know to do algorithmically
and what we know to be impossible
algorithmically so at this point
can't prove that we can only we can only
prove a strong lower bound for the
intersection of polynomial meaning
half-spaces so if you consider you know
a polytope with lots of facets then we
can show that that has high statistical
query dimension but if you consider just
the intersection of two half spaces then
questions
[Applause]